Ich hab den Sponsorheader vergessen.
F5
So.
Ja, ich hab den Titel vergessen anzupassen,
deswegen muss ich schon mal neu starten.
Muss ich mal gucken, dass ich hier nichts vergesse.
Ich bin ja nicht so der Sponsoring-Experte.
Muss man bei Twitch eigentlich auch
Sponsored oder sowas den Titel schreiben?
Ich bin da
Plan und bei YouTube kenne ich mich besser aus
So genau
Wir müssen mal ausprobieren
Ich muss für Titel anpassen
Den Stream neu starten
Ja damit er im Wort richtig heißt
Das Wort nimmt immer den ersten Stream
Hast du jetzt noch
Ein Ukraine Last bekommen
Man kann nie genug
Nasses haben
Oder seht ihr das anders, Chat?
Also komm
Unter 5 verschiedenen Nasses tut es nicht, oder?
guckt euch die Videos von
wie heißt der, wie heißt der Kerl
auf YouTube nochmal, der daheim
Kubernetes laufen hat
auf nem Proxmox Cluster
und damit nix betreibt, TechnoTim
jetzt weiß ich's wieder, der hat auch
5 Nasses und dann nochmal
irgendwie
in nem Rechenzentrum sich eingemietet
oder so. Für nix.
Da können wir das auch.
23 wird's eng.
Ja, da muss man Prioritäten setzen.
Muss halt andere Sachen rausfliegen.
Dass es nass reinpasst.
Ich muss euch was anderes erzählen gleich.
Erstmal Chat.
Wobei ich warte mal,
bis der Stream richtig...
Ich bin enttäuscht
enttäuscht von euch, Chat.
Ich bin schwer enttäuscht hier.
Da muss ich aber warten, bis ihr alle da seid,
damit ich euch das mal sagen kann.
Vorher
machen wir mal den Linux-Mini-PC an
und machen Updates.
Und was machen wir dann?
Chat, was machen wir nach Updates?
Essenziell
Reboot machen wir dann.
Genau.
Okay, ihr kennt das schon.
Streamst du gerade aus einer Wüste?
Ne, aber der Monat ist noch lang.
Hatte ich apurett mal gesagt.
Dubai ist das neue Meta oder irgend so ein Plötzchen.
Aber gut, der macht auch den Insi-Modus.
Kann sich an den Scheiß noch jemand erinnern?
Der hat auch schon viel Blödsinn erzählt
Ist der nicht im Knast?
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Das war Simon Desue, der da irgendwo im Knast ist
Weil er sich mit Drogen erwischt hat
Tja
Manchmal muss ich ehrlich sagen
Hält sich mein Mitleid wirklich in Grenzen
Ey, was ist das für ein Kack?
Also nicht, dass ich sonst so der großartige
Dass ich sonst so viel Mitleid hätte
Ihr wisst, ne, zwischenmenschliche Sachen
Ist bei mir nicht so
Oh, ich brauch was zu trinken
Egal, geh ich in einer halben Stunde oder so
Ich hab heute gedacht, ich mach mal
Bisschen was abgedrehteres
Und zwar bin ich erst
Eine halbe Stunde Fahrrad gefahren hier
oder 35 Minuten ungefähr,
Fahrrad gefahren auf meinem Indoor-Trainer.
Volle Pulle.
Na, was heißt volle Pulle?
So ungefähr um die 200 Watt.
Ungefähr.
Bisschen weniger.
So, zwischen, zwischen,
es hat ein bisschen geschwankt,
sagen wir mal zwischen 180 und 210,
so je nachdem, was war.
Bin ich 35 Minuten ziemlich,
ziemlich ordentlich Fahrrad gefahren.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht,
jetzt ziehe ich mich schnell um
und gehe gleich eine Runde rennen.
Und da habe ich erst mal gemerkt, wie hart das für Triathlon-Leute sein muss.
Du hast ja richtig Matsch in den Beinen für die ersten 500 Meter oder so.
Das ist echt nicht ohne.
Ich habe erst mal gedacht, boah ey, packst du es?
Aber so nach 500 Meter, so nach einem halben Kilometer oder so, war das kein Problem mehr.
Dann ging es wieder.
Max, wie teuer Server mit Epic, 9254 und 512 GB RAM und Enterprise Level Shit.
ich habe keine Ahnung, woher soll ich das wissen?
Ich kaufe bei uns auf der Arbeit
keine Server, keine Hardware
und ich kenne mich mit
aktueller Desktop-Hardware auch nicht richtig aus.
Ich kenne mich immer nur mit Hardware aus,
wenn ich mir selbst einen neuen Rechner kaufen will.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ist das überhaupt
eine neue CPU? Also ich kann jetzt zumindest
schon sagen, dass wahrscheinlich der RAM teurer sein wird
als die CPU.
Von wann ist denn der hier?
Vierte Generation, das muss wohl relativ was Neueres sein.
Naja, ja, naja.
Was Neueres ist gut gesagt.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du sogar ECC-RAM brauchst, oder?
Oder was heißt brauchst?
Dass du auch ECC-RAM haben willst.
Aber wahrscheinlich guckst du nach einem...
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Aber es muss wahrscheinlich kein S0-Dim, S-O-Dim, wie soll man das richtig aussprechen, sein, sondern normal großer RAM-Sockel.
Dann ist es zumindest einen Ticken billiger.
Aber 500, ohne Scheiß, wir können mal gucken, 512 GB RAM sind brutals teuer aktuell.
Wir können ja mal gucken, was 512, was das kostet, das würde mich jetzt auch mal interessieren.
Du hast schon eine Nvidia-Karte.
Was hast du denn vor?
Willst du da
irgendwelches lokales KI-Zeug mitmachen?
Oder wie?
Also hier, DDR5.
ECC.
Äh, nach was?
Den da, oder?
Chat, ist das richtig?
Das sind die normalen, ne?
Hier, Formfaktor Dim, ECC.
Guck mal, du kriegst da überhaupt keine 512 Gig rein mit dem normalen Zeug, was du dir so kaufen kannst.
Alter, ist das teuer.
WTF?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ach ne, warte mal, Air Dim, genau.
Air Dim.
Aber alter ist das teuer
Guckt euch das mal an
Das ist ja
Sag mal
Ich war doch das letzte Mal schon geschockt
Ist
Ne AliExpress ist ordentlich günstiger
Ist das denn
Nochmal teurer geworden
Okay
Server haben in der Regel vier
Also mindestens vier Bänke
Das heißt du kannst
128er Kids nehmen
Oder wie viel Bänke hast du
5000 euro
Für 128 g gramm die sind die sind aber ganz dicht
Okay, komm, wir hoffen jetzt einfach mal, du hast ein bisschen...
Du hast ein bisschen mehr RAM-Bänke, okay?
Es ist aber immer noch...
Es ist aber billiger, es ist billiger.
Okay, okay, dann brauchst du 8 RAM-Bänke.
Brauchst du...
Da kommst du aber halt mit irgendwelchen Consumer-Boards nicht weit.
Je nachdem, was du bauen willst.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ey, ey, das ist aber schon teuer, ne?
Das muss man, warte mal, mal 8.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, alter.
14.000 Euro.
Krasser Scheiß.
Hä?
Und das ist der billigste.
Das ist jetzt auch nur 4.800.
Ja, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben hier, dass das...
Warten wir mal nur den hier.
Oh!
Oh, oh, warte mal!
Wir waren...
Leute, hart gedroppt!
Guck mal, wir waren schon mal bei 3000 Euro und es ist hart gedroppt auf 1000...
Nur 1750!
Das ist doch Zufall, weil das jetzt so eine kleine Sample-Size hat, oder?
Wie sieht das bei normalem RAM aus?
Also hier nochmal alles zählen
2x16 machen wir mal, okay
2x16
Das ist, ist das ein bisschen
günstiger geworden wieder?
Ne, nicht, nicht nennenswert
Wir waren mal, wir waren mal hier in der Spitze
bei 419
Und jetzt sind wir bei 3, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Aber es ist halt nichts im Vergleich
davor. Das ist so
krass. Und ECC-Ram noch mehr.
Ne. Also
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das jetzt der beste Zeitpunkt ist, sowas zu
bauen.
Ich hab das bei uns auch mitgekriegt.
Bei uns,
die Server auf der Arbeit,
ich mein, ich selbst kümmere mich nicht um Hardware-Einkauf,
aber ich kenn Leute, die sich mit Hardware-Einkauf
kümmern.
Die Hardware-Preise
sind ums Zehnfache,
das ist jetzt kein Spaß, ja,
ums Zehnfache fast teurer geworden.
Das ist brutal, oder?
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Ums Zehnfache.
Die sind bei uns auf der Arbeit
jetzt sogar schon so weit,
dass sie Server weiter betreiben wollen,
ohne Support-Vertrag.
Weil der Scheiß so teuer ist.
Na gut, okay.
Das stimmt nicht ganz.
Okay, ich muss das korrigieren.
Die wollen die Server weiter betreiben.
Ohne offiziellen Support vom Hersteller.
Sie kaufen sich dann von irgendeinem Drittanbieter.
Es ist heute Sponsort-Stream.
Soll ich das noch in den Titel schreiben?
Ähm, das erkennt man doch anhand der Ausrufezeichen.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das...
Muss ich das in Titel schreiben?
Nee, einfach nur das in Titel schreiben, gut.
Es ist ja auch nicht...
Der Inhalt ist ja nicht sponsort.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Genau, die wollen sich dann Support bei einem Drittanbieter kaufen.
Was auch immer das bedeutet.
Chat, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie soll Support
Also mal angenommen, ihr kauft jetzt einen Server von IBM oder so
Ja, oder Lenovo, was weiß ich
Dell, HP, ist auch egal
Wie soll ein Drittanbieter Support aussehen?
Also, ich meine, die können ja nichts wirklich machen an der Kiste
Die können Hardware tauschen, ja, okay
Die können vielleicht irgendwie Lüfter 3D drucken oder so
Und dann da einbaut
Aber was die nicht machen können ist
Wenn zum Beispiel die Firma einen Bug hat, den fixen
Nun gut, da könnte man jetzt sagen
IBM fix auch keine Firmware-Bugs
Aber die könnten wenigstens
Drittanbieter könnten das
Das verstehe ich nicht
Aber das wollen sie, also ihr müsst euch vorstellen
Die haben bei uns richtig krass Asche
Aber überlegen wirklich Server ohne offiziellen Herstellersupport
Laufen zu lassen
Ja, wenn wir jetzt bei, hier
Delo, wenn wir bei den Amis jetzt wären
Dann bräuchte man Disclaimer
Das Verwenden eines Nasses kann
Achtung, das Verwenden eines Nasses
Kann zu schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden führen
Da kommt dann so ein fetter Aufkleber drauf
Das ist hier, auf meiner alten Tastatur hinten
War auch so ein Ding drauf
So ein Ami-Disclaimer
dass das Verwenden einer Tastatur zu schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden führen kann.
Moin.
Ja, Vendor-Login.
Aber jetzt kann ich euch mal was Lustiges erzählen.
Weil, wo es da gerade darum ging, dass die Kohle haben.
Wir hatten letztens in unserem Projekt Daily, hat jemand gesagt,
Ja, also wir partnern da ja auch mit verschiedenen anderen Finanzdienstleistern und Unternehmen aus der Finanzbranche. Da partnern wir bei unserem Blockchain-Projekt mit denen.
und da hat letztens einer erzählt, ja die, ich sag jetzt nicht den Namen, ne, ja die XXXY,
die testen jetzt auch mal den Fehlerfall von irgendeinem Anbieter, schließt quasi die Blockchain
und sie wollen quasi Kryptowerte wegtransferieren von einer Blockchain auf die anderen, die testen das jetzt
und die haben da eine Test-Transaktion gemacht
von 80 Millionen.
Da habe ich mir erst mal gedacht,
Moment, Moment, jetzt, ja wartet mal,
jetzt muss ich mal nachfragen.
Jetzt muss ich mal nachfragen. Das heißt,
die hauen da einfach 80
Millionen drauf,
um das zu testen, also zum Test oder was.
Und so, ja, ja, machen sie.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay,
Bank macht Bankdinger.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, wer kennt es nicht?
einfach mal mit 80 Millionen testen.
Easy.
Echtzeit oder wo man
10% Gebühr bezahlt. Hä?
Ne, ne.
Echte Kryptowährung.
Und sobald du da auf den Knopf drückst,
ist es da.
Ja, die haben genug.
Das juckt die nicht.
Aber das ist schon geil, ne?
Du bezahlst...
Oh, wie heißt das?
Ist das Gas-Fee?
Da gibt es so ein spezielles Wort für.
Dass du dann höhere Prioritäten
quasi kriegst in dem aktuellen Block.
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
War das eigentliche Budget
für die Hardware?
Ja, na gut. Hey, von 80 Millionen
könnte man sich wenigstens RAM kaufen.
Leute, wenn die mir die 80 Millionen überweisen,
Dann kriegt ihr von mir auch Ramriegel.
Leider steht das wohl nicht zur Debatte.
Aber sag mal so, ich hätte da nichts dagegen.
Chat, jetzt wo ihr alle da seid.
Naja, sind nicht alle da.
Sind so die Hälfte.
Die Hälfte der Leute sind da.
Aber ich muss jetzt mal was sagen, Chat.
Hier.
Ich bin enttäuscht von euch.
Und jetzt haltet euch fest.
Ich werde euch auch genau erzählen, warum.
Ich habe für diesen Monat, also Juni,
habe ich ein Sponsoring laufen mit Ugreen und Seagate.
Wie ihr übrigens auch im Titel des Streams seht.
Und mit den Kommandos könnt ihr euch Links anzeigen lassen im Chat,
wo ihr dann Festplatten besonders günstig kaufen könnt,
Nasses besonders günstig kaufen könnt.
Wir gucken uns das auch gleich nochmal an.
Aber, aber, jetzt kommt's.
Ich habe das Banner bei mir auf dem Kanal.
Guck mal.
Ich habe dieses Banner hier auf meinem Kanal.
Da sieht man auch den Link unten.
Dieses Banner habe ich am Montag reingemacht.
Und am Dienstag haben die sich bei mir beschwert per Mail,
dass dort, wie kann das sein,
dass da schon 2000 Klicks drauf
gekommen wären. Irgendjemand
von euch hat meinen RevLink
viewbottet.
Also,
wer auch immer
meinen RevLink viewbottet.
RF-Programmer,
dich habe ich schon im Verdacht gehabt,
weil ich habe dich im Chat gesehen,
dass du aktiv warst. Also, Chat,
Chat, wer auch immer meinen
Raffling-View bottet,
sollte das bitte
sein lassen, okay?
Also mehr, ich hab auch gesagt,
mehr als sagen kann ich's nicht.
Als wir grad dabei sind,
Chat, guck doch mal hier.
Ich muss hier ab und zu mal ein bisschen Sellout machen.
Ihr müsst übrigens mal drauf achten.
Alle 30,
Ich mache das jetzt mal von Hand.
Alle 30 Minuten...
Geht das so?
Äh.
Warum kann ich das nicht auslösen?
Okay, Sekunde.
Sekunde, Chat.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Wir machen das jetzt gleich.
Jetzt aber, oder?
Jetzt.
Alle 30 Minuten
Sollte eigentlich jetzt dieses Banner hier kommen
30 Minuten soll eigentlich dieses Banner hier kommen
So und ihr könnt mit
Etwas Low Res
Ey
Ich hab mir das Banner nicht
Ich hab das exakt so eingestellt
Wie die mir das geschickt haben
Das Banner ist in der Tat
etwas Slow Rats.
Aber ich glaube, das soll diesen
so Gift-Vibe
soll das geben. Was auch immer.
Die haben sich
da bestimmt schon was bei gedacht.
Zumindest, ihr könnt mit Ausrufezeichen
Ukraine und Ausrufezeichen
Seagate und alternativ auch
Ausrufezeichen Alternate,
ja, das kommt alles der
gleiche Link raus. Könnt ihr mal ausprobieren.
Gibt es einen Rev-Link und zwar
kommt ihr dann hier auf
bei Alternate im Shop raus.
Das wird aber GIF ausgesprochen.
Das wird GIF ausgesprochen.
Für mich ist es weder GIF...
Wie sprichst du, Alfred?
Wie sprichst du Jason aus?
Jason? Jason? Oder gar
Jason?
Das letzte...
war klar. Naja, sogar
der Jason-Erfinder
hat gesagt, es wird angeblich,
also das hat er glaube ich
so halb als Witz gemeint,
das wird Jezor ausgesprochen.
Aber jetzt
gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Guckt mal, es gibt über meinen Revlink
günstige Ukraine Nasses und
Festplatten. Unter anderem
gibt es ein, ich glaube Arm, das müssen wir uns
gleich mal angucken, Arm-Based Nass,
was besonders energiesparend
ist und für kleine Sachen ohne Probleme
ausreicht. Ich bin ja immer
Fan von RAID 1, das wisst
ihr ja, und RAID 1 kannst du hier drin super betreiben.
Ich meine, wofür das jetzt vielleicht nix
ist, wenn ihr 150TB
irgendwelche Daten speichern müsst.
Wenn ihr aber einfach nur ein NAS braucht,
ein bisschen Backup zu machen,
packt da
zwei 24TB-Platten
rein oder fangt mit
2x6TB an.
Könnt ihr entweder
YOLO RAID 0 machen, was ich nicht empfehlen würde,
oder ihr macht RAID 1.
Dann habt ihr relativ günstig,
das ist wirklich super preis also wurde mir versichert wir können wir gleich nach gucken
ob das stimmt ich hoffe das stimmt sonst wirkt das jetzt ein bisschen blöd kräftige für den
sub wir gucken mal gleich nach wie die preise von 6 terabyte platten sind und dann ist das zum
einstieg nicht schlecht was ich hier was hier bei raid steht das bezieht sich immer stark von aus
auf das offizielle os ihr könnt damit potenziell alles mögliche machen was euer betriebssystem
dem hergibt. Also wenn ihr
Proxmox drauf installiert oder
irgendwas anderes und ZFS-Rate macht, könnt
ihr damit auch ZFS-Rate, beziehungsweise
das Gegenstück bei ZFS
zu Rate 1 machen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal kurz, also was kosten
hier?
Nehmen wir mal die 6TB.
Seagate Einwolf.
Ich hoffe, ich schneide mir jetzt nicht ins eigene
Fleisch, wenn ich mir das angucke.
Seagate Einwolf
6TB.
Wir vergleichen das jetzt mal.
Wie gesagt, mir wurde versichert, dass in Top-Preise.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Äh.
Hallo?
6 Terabyte?
Ne, das ist irgendwie refurbished oder sowas.
Iron Wolf Pro, 6 Terabyte.
200.
Ja gut, ja gut, Amazon weiß, also...
Keine ahnung wie vertrauenswürdig keine ahnung kann ich zu sagen aber die gucken wir die normalen shops dann guckte man hier bei den normalen shops
Kostra 112 und über ein alter link ist für
also da kann man wirklich nichts sagen
Das ist preislich echt nicht schlecht und was kriegt ihr nur
über meinen reff link den link gibt es in der channel beschreibung also hier
oder Ausrufezeichen Seagate,
Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen
Alternate im Chat.
So, und jetzt
gucken wir uns mal.
Ja, aber das sind eindeutig die... Ach, Moment,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was sind das denn für welche?
Nicht, dass ich euch Mist erzählt habe.
Das sind die Nicht-Pro.
Die normalen Nicht-Pro
sind das.
Die da.
Die da nicht.
Ja, wo ist sie? Gibt es da keine 6 TB hier?
Hä? 4T?
Okay, whatever. Ich bin zu blöd, die Platte zu finden.
Varianten.
Ja, okay, das ist aber 4 Terabyte.
12 Terabyte?
8 Terabyte? 4 Terabyte?
6 Terabyte? Aber das ist nicht die.
Das ist die nicht. Das ist eine andere.
Sieht zumindest anders aus.
Okay, Chat, ich bin offiziell zu einem dummen Preisvergleich.
Zumindest sind das super Preise.
Das erste.
Gucken wir mal.
Der sieht mir so refurbished aus irgendwie.
Wobei.
Ah, nee.
Guck mal.
248.
Egal, aber hier könnte er mich über meinen Raffling supporten.
Ach, die ist das. Okay.
Gut.
Besser. Besser. Chat.
Okay, den Stream schicke ich
vielleicht besser nicht zur Auswertung dahin.
Ähm, hier.
Das ist besser.
Gut.
Genau. Ja. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied
zu der und zur anderen ist.
zumindest 279 Euro
zu, wir hätten glaube ich nach
dieser, nach dieser ID suchen
sollen.
279 Euro zu, ich meine immerhin.
Immerhin könnte er
7 Euro sparen.
Und was noch viel besser ist,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal das aktuelle
NAS hier an, was die da haben, mit 2x Siegel.
Also ich glaube Bundle-Preise sind auch ganz
gut. Das hier
ist das kleine NAS von Ugreen.
Das schauen wir uns jetzt mal kurz zusammen an.
Ach, das ist ein Intel N100 Quadcopter.
Okay, das Ding sollte sehr energiesparend sein.
Kommt mit 8G Gramm.
Ja, ich meine, der 8G Gramm ist ja fast schon mehr wert als das NAS.
Alternate hat allgemein immer ganz gute Sachen, ja.
Okay, es ist eine x86 Kiste.
Das heißt, man kann auf jeden Fall alles drauf laufen lassen, was man will.
Es hat 2,5 Gig
Netzwerk.
Es hat 2 NVMe-Stellungen.
Das Ding ist gar nicht mal übel.
Hat der, jetzt, jetzt kommt's.
Jetzt kommt's.
Hat der hier, welches, gibt's hier
ähm, technische Daten?
Wartet mal, jetzt guckt mal,
mal was.
Wo steht denn jetzt hier die
CPU? Weiß nicht.
Die haben bestimmt
Crypto Extensions.
Weil dann wäre das richtig gut.
Wir gucken mal kurz
bei Intel.
Hat das Ding AES?
AES?
AES New?
Heißt das nicht irgendwas mit
NI?
Ach, New Instructions.
Der hat AES NI. Also sprich, der kann
also in Hardware, beziehungsweise extra Krypto-Krypto-Befehl-Satz,
damit kriegt man richtig schnell einen Durchsatz,
also quasi nahezu,
aber wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben,
aber ich sage jetzt trotzdem mal,
nahezu Native Performance trotz Encryption.
Also sprich, wenn ihr was verwendet,
wie beispielsweise, wenn ihr unter Linux Lux zum Beispiel verwendet
und einen kompatiblen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus,
dann kann das extra schnell ver- und entschlüsselt werden,
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich bin dafür, immer seine Daten zu verschlüsseln auf Festplatten, weil dann könnt ihr sie einfach in den Müll schmeißen.
Dann müsst ihr euch ja keine Gedanken machen, ah, ist kaputt, ist nicht mehr lesbar, will ich wirklich meine sensiblen Sachen in den Müll schmeißen, was noch irgendjemand wiederherstellen kann?
Einfach, Bäm, bei Seagate habt ihr glaube ich noch diese komische Daten-Rescue-Versicherung, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, weiß ich nicht, ob das taugt.
aber das ist auf jeden Fall gut.
Hier könnt ihr die Daten verschlüsseln
und zwar relativ schnell. Also,
ich sage jetzt einfach mal was, ohne dass ich es selbst ausprobiert
habe. Also ich würde sagen,
2,5 Gig
kriegt ihr
mit einem RAID 1 und
Encryption komplett
saturated.
Das ist ein richtig
gutes Gerät. Und das sage ich jetzt
weil es weil es falls sponsort ist mit 391 allein ist ist auch ist der ram inklusive ja der ram
ist inklusive oder arbeitsspeicher vorhanden ach dick gestern als ich mir den link angeguckt
habe, gab es glaube ich das NAS auch noch alleine zu kaufen.
So, gucken vielleicht, müsst ihr öfters mal gucken,
vielleicht ändert sich ja auch noch was an dem Link.
Aber an sich ist das ein echt gutes Gerät.
So, das habe ich noch sehr laut gemacht.
Aber schon geil,
dass mein
Link viewbotted wird, oder?
Chat-Gerät.
So, aber jetzt ganz
wichtig update package ab jetzt ist heute wirklich nur ganz kurzer stream ich bin nur
noch eineinhalb stunden oder so da ich mache ich habe den stream hauptsächlich
gemacht dass ich einmal sagen kann please aufhören zu view button
warum ist das so langsam
Ich muss ja nochmal was loswerden.
Ich habe heute Morgen zum ersten Mal auf der neuen Arbeit mitbekommen,
so von außen betrachtet, wie ein Systemausfall der höchsten Kategorie gehandhabt wird.
Es sind, ich sage jetzt nicht was, es sind zumindest Systeme kaputt gegangen,
Wo mir mein Chef erzählt hat, das kostet, also die hatten mal einen Ausfall von glaube 5 Minuten.
Und da sind ihnen Sachen von knapp 50 Millionen entgangen.
Oder 60, 50, ne doch 50 Millionen.
In 5 Minuten.
Also das ist echt schlecht, wenn da Systeme ausfallen.
Und heute Morgen war das wohl soweit.
Glücklicherweise keine Linux Server oder sonst irgendwas.
Ich hatte damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ich konnte das mal so von außen beobachten.
Und man muss echt sagen, die handhaben das um Längen besser als mein alter Arbeitgeber.
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber sah das ungefähr so aus.
Machen wir mal ein Beispiel bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber, was ähnlich schwerwiegend war.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so teuer.
Aber wir hatten da ein System, was Leute im Außendienst benutzt haben.
Und die kamen halt über Loadbalancer von außen rein.
Und manchmal hatten die Loadbalancer Probleme.
So, Loadbalancer geht kaputt, Außendienst hat Probleme zu arbeiten, dann lief das bei uns eigentlich erst einmal so, also zumindest erstmal relativ Standard, Monitoring-Meldung geht auf, man hat es ja meistens relativ schnell mitgekriegt, du loggst dich auf dem System ein und kaum warst du auf dem System eingeloggt, steht der Chef von der Hotline neben dir und sagt, und, wie lange dauert es?
Er hat gesagt, keine Ahnung. Ich habe gerade die Meldung gekriegt und mich eingeloggt.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was kaputt ist.
Ja, kannst du schon ungefähr eine grobe Schätzung abgeben?
Nee, kann ich nicht. Ja, aber ich muss den Leuten noch irgendwas sagen.
Und damals war ich noch ein bisschen gemein, was das angeht.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, sag einfach mal fünf Stunden.
Das kann man doch nicht so kommunizieren. Fünf Stunden, was sollen denn die Leute machen?
Denkt ihr was aus, Mann? Das ist nicht mein Job, mir sich irgendwas auszudenken.
Ich weiß es doch nicht. Und wenn er mir auf den Keks geht,
Umso schlechter kann ich das Ganze fixen.
Okay, okay.
So, der Typ ist dann permanent,
also ich rede jetzt nicht vom aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
da gab es bei der Bank einen Außendienst.
Klar, die haben Leute, die bei daheim vorbeikommen
und Leute beraten und sowas.
Klar.
Natürlich haben die einen Außendienst.
Ja, so, und der ist dann quasi permanent
so im Dunstradius
von meinem Arbeitsplatz rumgelaufen
und hat laufend gefragt. Dann kam
nach fünf Minuten, nach fünf weiteren Minuten
oder so, mein Chef noch rein.
So, und wenn es dann noch länger gedauert hat,
kam nach weiteren fünf Minuten oder so
noch der Abteilungsleiter rein. Und wir hatten
Ausfälle schon beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Da hatte ich
drei Leute hinter mir stehen,
die mir permanent über die Schulter geguckt
haben, als würden
die da irgendwas verstehen, was da gerade
passiert, ja? Weil sie irgendwie gedacht haben,
das geht dann schneller.
Ich muss mich dann auch manchmal beschweren zwischendurch, dass ich mich nicht konzentrieren kann, wenn da drei Leute mir über die Schulter gucken.
Aber ich sage, das geht nicht schneller.
Ihr verlangsamt das eher gerade noch, ja.
Das war schon ätzend.
Oh ja, und wie gesagt, in dem neuen Laden wird das Ganze viel besser gehandhabt.
Also, mein Chef war auch am Start, der Abteilungsleiter war auch am Start.
Aber die haben alle keine Hektik und keine Panik gemacht.
die haben relativ ruhig telefoniert haben die leute arbeiten lassen haben
sie ab und zu mal ein status geben lassen haben dann gesagt okay sie hauen
wieder ab um den nicht auf kicks zu gehen also kannst du dich echt nicht
beschweren und ich gehe mal davon aus der fehler war dadurch schneller
gefixt als hätten die dahinter um wenn wenn die dahinter umgesprungen
übrigens chat könnte mir mal gefallen tun könnt ihr mich könnt ihr mich daran
erinnern als mein sellout banner auf ploppt weil irgendwie verpeile ich das wahrscheinlich und ich
muss so oft im stream was sagen zu meinem sellout banner dass das dauert aber nur 30 sekunden oder
so sehr laut reminder ausrufezeichen wüste müssen wir da machen sagt silva
dankeschön
deshalb ja sowas bräuchten wir da das stein hat auch so schreibt glaube ich
gar nicht gesehen. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pock Subscription.
Kannst du auf der Tastatur schreiben, ohne hinzugucken?
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Das ist getippt,
ohne auf die
Tastatur
zu gucken.
Naja, ich würde sagen,
nicht sonderlich gut.
Aber ich kann die meisten Sachen, die ich Terminal-technisch so brauche, relativ blind tippen.
So solche Sachen zum Beispiel.
Also das kann ich immer. Das muss ich dann hingucken.
Pipes und so. Also, Steuerung C.
Also die Sachen, die man im Terminal braucht, die kann ich zum größten Teil ohne auf die Tastatur zu gucken.
Aber wenn ich irgendwelche Texte schreiben muss, da muss ich ab und zu mal auf die Tastatur gucken.
Also ich bin keiner, der 100%ig hier 10 Finger blind schreiben kann.
Wie geht's? Erstaunlich gut in letzter Zeit.
Haben wir jetzt Updates gemacht? Ja, ne? Wir haben Updates gemacht.
Updates. Excellent.
Und jetzt müssen wir machen...
Reboot.
Du meinst hier, wenn ich Buchstaben vertausche
Das ist egal, ja, das stimmt
Aber ich vertausche relativ selten was
Ja, ja
Das nehme ich immer noch
Das werde ich auch noch eine Weile nehmen
Das steht ja sogar im Beipackzettel
Man soll das mindestens 6 Monate länger nehmen
Als man Probleme hat
Es gibt ja irgendwie Videospiele und Splinter
Ich weiß, es gibt schon seit 50 Jahren oder so irgendwelche Kurse für 10 Finger Blindschreiben und so.
Habe ich aber nie gemacht.
Also ich würde sagen, ich kann so zu 80% Blindschreiben.
Wenn es kompliziertere Sachen sind, muss ich ab und zu mal auf die Tastatur gucken.
Es ist die größte Quality of Life.
Chat, wir können ja, wir können ja.
Max, Max, es ist aber halt super langweilig.
Ich wollte sagen, wir machen einen Stream, wo ich das lerne.
Das Problem ist, das ist abfacklangweilig zuzugucken.
Das machen wir nicht.
Du hast es zufällig...
Wie setzt man denn sowas zufällig ab?
Ja.
Das ist gut, wenn es dir dann besser geht.
Dann hast du die eigentliche Sache wahrscheinlich schon überwunden gehabt.
Und hast jetzt nur noch die Nachteile davon gehabt.
Aber generell würde ich nicht, würde ich nicht das einfach absetzen.
Generell, alle Pillen würde ich nicht einfach absetzen ohne Rücksprache.
Dann überleg dir mal, es geht dir jetzt mal irgendwie nicht mehr so gut.
Da musst du wieder neu anfangen und dann dauert es wieder vier Wochen, bis der Kram wirkt und so.
Das ist alles nicht so, nicht so dolle.
Ich nehme das erstmal weiter.
Ich habe ja auch eigentlich keine Nebenwirkungen.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme.
So, weiter im Text.
Was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Achso, rebooten wollen.
Ah, geil.
Jetzt habe ich schon ein Alias eingerichtet und
wenn mal das funktioniert.
Habe ich alles geupdatet?
Ich glaube schon.
Wie läuft es mit Nextcloud?
Wieso? Wie meinst du?
Ich habe Nextcloud nicht...
Also doch, ich habe Nextcloud installiert bei mir lokal, weil ich da seit Jahren so ein Adressbuch drin habe.
Aber ich mag Nextcloud nicht.
Und sobald ich mich mal ein bisschen damit beschäftige, wie ich das Adressbuch einfach woanders hin exportieren kann,
dann werde ich Nextcloud nicht mehr installieren.
Das wissen Leute, die wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen länger dabei sind.
Ich bin überhaupt kein großer Nextcloud-Fan.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Preisfrage.
Was kann ich weniger leihen?
Nextcloud oder C++?
Da würde ich sagen, eindeutig C++.
Nextcloud ist ja zumindest noch irgendwie der Versuch, ein ordentliches Produkt rauszuhauen und es ordentlich zu machen.
C++ ist auch der Versuch, ein ordentliches Produkt rauszuhauen.
Das will ich denen mal gar nicht absprechen.
aber das ergebnis ist halt es hässlich mögt das das am hässlichsten möglichte deswegen ist halt
c++ die hässlichste programmiersprache die nicht hässlich sein will also nicht bei nix cloud halt
immer nervt ist dass das einfach so zu stückwerk unfertig wirkt ja notiz app gut gedacht elfter
features von funzen nicht oder sind nicht da und so dass das zieht sich bei nextcloud komplett
durch. Und dazu kommt, dass
was die letzten Jahre in Nextcloud
an neuen Features dazu gekommen ist, ja?
Also, dass du besser externen Sachen
sharen kannst, neues Permission-Zeug.
Diese ganze Teams-Ersatz-Geschichte
juckt mich halt privat
überhaupt nicht.
Ich musste heute auf der Arbeit was mit
Fortran machen, sagt McFly.
Ja? Was denn?
Was musstest du in Fortran machen?
Das würde mich tatsächlich jetzt mal interessieren.
Kobol.
Also über Kobol stolpere ich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch manchmal.
Aber nur indirekt.
Ja?
Also.
Weil ich das höre von irgendwelchen Mainframe-Leuten oder so.
Auf der alten Arbeit bin ich tatsächlich öfters über Kobold gestolpert.
Da hatten wir irgendeinen Kobold zu Java Cross Compiler.
Na klar haben wir noch einen Host.
Einen Kobold zu Java Cross Compiler hatten wir da.
Weil das Kobold Zeug nicht mehr richtig lief, haben sie es zu Java Cross Compiled und dann mit Java ausgeführt.
Aber letztendlich haben sie halt immer noch ihre UR Kobold Sachen verwendet.
Sind Cobol und Fortran Leute nicht die höchstbezahlten Software-Engineers?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich könnte mir das vorstellen, aber davon gibt es halt auch nicht viele.
Ja, du hast halt eine Handvoll Jobs, die wahrscheinlich super bezahlt werden müssen,
weil das so business-critical Zeug ist.
Wie gut
ist
KI bei Kobol
und Fortran?
Was meint ihr?
Also ich glaube, die sind
wahrscheinlich
trainiert
mit
Massen 50 Jahre
altem Fortran und Kobol Code.
Aber ob da was Gescheites bei rauskommt,
bin ich mir nicht sicher, weil
die sind halt überhaupt nicht darauf optimiert,
Kobold und Fortran gut zu können.
Was ist eigentlich?
Ich muss... Klar, es gibt
seit über 50 Jahren
Kobold-Programme.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem
Bun-Rewrite von...
Äh, nicht aus dem Bun.
Aus dem Rust-Rewrite
von Bun geworden?
Da sind die Flame-Posts
in letzter Zeit weniger geworden.
Aber die sind immer noch da dran, oder?
Die haben nicht wieder zurückgeschwenkt, oder?
Die sind immer noch dran an ihrer...
Rust.
Oder?
Fragezeichen.
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Ja.
Definitiv kein KI-Comet.
MDX.
Die sind aber hart am Vibe-Coden, oder?
TypeScript.
Was?
wie typescript dachte
keiner
wo ist dann
source
bahn
Cor?
Sig?
Ach, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Da liegt die...
Da liegt die Rust-Sachen
direkt neben den Sig-Sachen.
Oh, das wird mich, glaube ich,
heftig verwirren. Da würde ich immer das Falsche aufmachen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber so vom...
Wie nennen wir es denn mal?
So vom Community Echo habe ich den Eindruck gehabt, dass der Rust Port von BAN nicht gut angekommen ist und sich BAN ein bisschen Vertrauenswürdigkeit verspielt hat.
Ich habe euch ja schon meine Meinung dazu gesagt.
Also ich denke, das ist so ein Marketing Stunt wieder von Anthropic.
Anthropic hat ja BAN gekauft und will jetzt damit zeigen, guckt mal hier, unsere KI hat ein komplettes Riesenprojekt.
Projekt, rewritten in Rust, konvertiert.
Es ist ja noch nicht mal gutes Rust.
Es ist zu 90% irgendwie, oder es hat glaube ich irgendwie 17.000 unsaved Rust-Aufrufe und sowas.
Also es macht nichts wirklich besser, dass es jetzt in Rust ist.
Nur dass du jetzt ganz viel untested Code hast.
Und ich meine mit untested nicht, dass Tests existieren, sondern halt Sachen, die Leute verwendet haben.
Also ich habe eher den Eindruck gehabt, das kam nicht so gut an, dass BUN in Rust rewritten wurde.
Aber schauen wir mal an, wie sich das entwickelt.
Entropic wird wahrscheinlich jetzt da Double Down machen und die SICK-Geschichte gar nicht mehr anfassen.
Du hattest doch mal erzählt, dass du eine Schlafgespräch-Aufnahme-App benutzt hattest.
Das ist mir irgendwie in den Kopf gekommen und ich probiere das mal.
Also, das ist so lange her, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, welche App das wohl gewesen sein muss.
Also ich habe bestimmt schon zwei Jahre oder so sowas nicht mehr verwendet.
Ich kann mich gar nicht daran erinnern.
Vielleicht habe ich das mal ausprobiert.
Leicht hab ich, warte mal
Das kann sein, dass ich das mal ausprobiert hab
Also was ich, was ich verwendet habe ist
Ich hab ne Sleep
In nem Video, okay
Boah, dann ist es ja noch länger her
Keine Ahnung
Weiß ich nicht
Also was ich, was ich ne ganze Weile verwendet hab
Ist so ein Sleep Tracker
Da, also, da kannst du
Also wenn du deine Garmin Uhr anziehst, kann die halt tracken, wie gut du schläfst.
Ich weiß, dass das umstritten ist, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, manche sagen, das ist eigentlich total Augenwischerei.
Es könnte sein, dass die Garmin Uhr bzw. die Garmin App dieses Feature auch hat
und ich das mal ausprobiert habe und ich das im Video erzählt habe.
Das kann sein.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich meine, ich werde dieses Jahr erst 42.
Was habe ich denn da für einen Krempel auf?
Doch.
Ich bin so oft kurz davor gewesen,
ein Video zu machen
auf YouTube die letzten Tage
und Wochen. Irgendwann
ist so der, der
der kritische Punkt erreicht.
Dann ist es nicht mehr aufzuhalten, dass ich ein Video mache.
Auf der anderen Seite, Max,
bevor du das machst,
willst du wirklich wissen, was du im Schlaf sagst?
Vielleicht sind es ja super weirde
Sachen.
Neue Serverraumtour mit den 5xNAS.
Leute, ich hab da kein NAS für bekommen, ne?
Für diese Sponsoring-Geschichte
hier.
Wie mich dieses Wallet nervt.
Also ich hab dieses
Nass hier nicht da.
Hätte ich das da,
dann hätten wir das tatsächlich mal in einem Stream
allein als Thema und wir würden uns
das angucken, wie gut das als
so Low Energy Nass performt.
Also quasi wie viel
Energie
das braucht Idle mit SSDs.
Und
das können wir doch.
Das gucken wir mal. Das interessiert mich.
Ach, die haben hier zwei Nasses zur Auswahl.
Das hier ist das Arm-Based-Nass, gell?
Das DH2300, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das ist Arm-Based.
Das muss noch mal eine Nummer energiesparender sein.
Oh, es kam gerade mal ein Banner.
Morgen, KS.
Ja.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja den Sellout gemacht.
Gerade noch mal.
Und ich muss an der Stelle auch nochmal betonen, die günstigen Preise kriegt ihr nur über meinen Link, sonst nicht, sonst ist es teurer.
Ja, und die Seite würde funktionieren, wenn meine Wallet mitspielt.
Und bitte nicht Viewport.
Jetzt hast du den Namen gefunden.
Äh, für was?
Ach, eine Physiksoftware zum Laufen bekommen.
Für Portran, krass.
Wie alt ist denn das Ding?
Ihr sollt nicht, ihr sollt nicht
View-Button auf meinen Rev-Link
Die haben sich bei mir schon beschwert
Okay, jetzt sind ein bisschen mehr Leute da
Jetzt kann ich es ja nochmal erzählen
Weil das ja irgendwie für Erheiterung gesorgt hat
Ich hab dieses Channel-Banner
Am Montag bei mir reingemacht
Weil das läuft den ganzen Monat
das Seagate Ukraine Alternate Sponsoring.
Das läuft den ganzen Monat.
Ich habe das Montag reingemacht
und am Dienstag haben die sich bei mir beschwert,
weil irgendjemand
mein Refling geviewbottet hat.
Und es da aus dem Nichts
2000 Aufrufe reinbekommen hat,
obwohl ich überhaupt nicht live war.
Aber was soll ich machen?
Ich habe halt High IQ Viewer.
Also, ich weiß es zu schätzen,
dass ihr denkt ihr helft mir damit aber das ding zu viewport mit unrealistischem traffic ist es auch nicht
ihr dürft gerne aufmachen und anklicken und noch lieber auch was darüber kaufen ja alles top
wurde dann wenigstens was gekauft das ist das ja bei 2000 klicks viewport da wird nichts gekauft da wird einfach nur geklickt
Du hast im März einen neuen Job angenommen.
Warte.
Okay, Sekunde.
Ich habe heute eh nichts geplant für den Stream weiter.
Kaufport-Chat.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, Ausrufezeichen Seagate, Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Alternet.
kriegt ihr meinen Link
mit günstigem Storage und
Ukraine-Nassus bei Alternate.
Und nachdem ich extra betonen soll,
dass ihr das nur über meinen Link kriegt,
ihr kriegt es nur über meinen Link.
Ich stecke etwas in der Misere,
schreibt das Sgt. Silver.
Vielleicht können wir darüber diskutieren.
Ich habe im März einen neuen Job angenommen,
bin aber irgendwie nicht so richtig happy.
Zu viel... Was?
zu viel haus soll ich dir mal sagen ich verstehe ein problem
ich habe auch die letzten jahre zu 80 90 prozent home office 90 prozent home office gemacht bin
immer nur meinen einen tag die woche gekommen das ist halt statistisch gesehen passt
Aber, seit ich da meine psychischen Probleme habe, gehe ich sehr gerne nach Frankfurt, weil es mich ablenkt und mir geht es viel besser danach, wenn ich in Frankfurt gewesen bin, als wenn ich nur daheim hocke.
Trotz Sport oder Ausflug machen oder sonst was.
Hört auf zu viewbotten, Leute!
Scheiße!
Ja gut, kann ich auch nichts machen.
Was soll ich machen? Ich kann es keinem verbieten.
Ich kann euch ja schlecht
Counter-D-Dossen oder so.
Und mir geht es viel besser,
seit ich nach Frankfurt regelmäßig fahre.
Manchmal ärgere ich mich morgens um 7 Uhr,
dass ich jetzt aufstehen muss bald
und fährst du mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit?
Nee, aber im Sommer
habe ich mir das fest vorgenommen,
dass ich das dieses Jahr öfters mache.
Die Strecke bin ich schon ein paar Mal abgefahren.
sind ungefähr 30 Kilometer nach Frankfurt und 30 Kilometer mittags zurück.
Das werde ich im Sommer jetzt machen, wenn richtig gutes Wetter ist.
Setze mich morgens aufs Fahrrad, fahre nach Frankfurt, bin ich in eineinhalb Stunden da.
Letztendlich ist es länger als mit der Bahn, ja, aber du bist halt komplett unabhängig.
Das kannst du viel besser planen.
Also insofern kann ich das tatsächlich verstehen, wenn jemand keinen Bock hat, Homeoffice zu machen.
Ich konnte das vor einem Jahr oder so noch nicht verstehen, jetzt kann ich es verstehen.
Team Lied nie Zeit, Kollegen in anderem Land, jemand Ideen.
Naja.
Die erste Idee, die ich habe, du bist noch in der Probezeit, du kommst jetzt relativ schnell raus.
Das Ding ist aber, vielleicht solltest du erst da abhauen, wenn du was Neues hast.
Weil, wenn du einen Job hast, bist du in einer viel besseren Position, dir einen neuen Job zu suchen.
Du hast einen Plan B.
Okay, ja dann.
Also, wenn du eine gute Alternative hast, ne?
wenn du eine gute Alternative hast, also wenn da die Konditionen passen,
wenn das Geld passt, wenn die Leute passen,
letztendlich so viel verlieren kannst du dabei ja nicht.
Du bist bei dem anderen Laden auch noch in der Probezeit.
Die könnten auch jederzeit sagen, wir haben keinen Bock mehr auf dich.
Und so bist du halt bei dem neuen Laden ein paar Wochen länger in Probezeit.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so wild.
Also ich sehe jetzt da nicht, dass du da groß was verlieren könntest.
Das Einzige, was vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht aussieht, ist,
wenn du den nächsten Arbeitgeber
also wenn du deinen Plan B
jetzt wieder innerhalb von ein paar Monaten wechselst
das sieht dann halt nicht so geil aus
falls du dich danach noch auf was anderes bewerben willst
0% Homeoffice öffentlicher Dienst
dir muss es gefallen
ich würde jetzt auch erstmal sagen
na ich weiß ja nicht
aber wenn du denkst
dass es was für dich ist
wir können das ja nicht besser beurteilen
Also ich hätte da keinen Bock drauf, ja. 0% Homeoffice ist für mich schon einmal fast Ausschluss-KO-Kriterium, würde ich nicht machen.
Weil es kann ja durchaus sein, dass du jetzt, wenn du, wenn du, du warst ein paar Wochen da und denkst dir,
ah, wäre doch mal schön wieder eine Runde Homeoffice und dann geht's nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir, ach fuck, wäre ich doch bei dem alten Laden geblieben.
Ich meine, was, was, was du ja durchaus machen könntest ist, du könntest jetzt mal testweise 1-2 Wochen nicht Homeoffice machen.
oder hat dein aktueller Arbeitgeber gar kein Office, wo du hinfahren könntest?
Kannst es ja mal ausprobieren.
Weil wenn du dann nach zwei Wochen schon sagst,
ey, ich hab doch keinen Bock drauf, ich will ja Homeoffice machen,
das ist vielleicht keine so gute Idee.
Aber die IT ist komplett leer.
Habt ihr feste Arbeitsplätze oder so?
Jeder kann sitzen, wo er will.
Weil dann setze ich einfach woanders hin.
Ich setze mich auch manchmal in andere Büros, wenn bei uns gar nichts los ist
In der Regel gehen mir ja andere Menschen auf den Sack
Deswegen mache ich das nicht oft, aber manchmal mache ich das
Der einzige Nachteil für mich aktuell, nach Frankfurt zu fahren und kein Homeoffice zu machen, ist
Man hat ein bisschen weniger Arbeitszeit, wegen dem Gependele
Und, und, ein großes Problem ist, wir haben eine gute Kantine mit stark, um nicht zu sagen, sehr stark subventioniertem Essen.
Ich habe schon wieder ein bisschen zugenommen. Also ein bisschen ist gut, 5 Kilo oder so habe ich zugenommen.
Dieses Jahr.
Aber ich gelobe Besserung.
Ich bin jetzt ja wieder viel mehr am Rennen und am Fahrradfahren.
Und ich fresse jetzt auch nicht mehr ganz so viel.
Das muss wieder weg.
Aber das ist der einzige Nachteil.
Da muss man keinen Schnitzel klauen.
Und ich muss dazu sagen, wer die Referenz nicht verstanden hat,
nein, ich habe nie einen Schnitzel geklaut.
Ich habe das nur beobachtet, wie Schnitzel geklaut wurden.
Okay.
Ja, habt ihr da gar nichts da?
Leute, Rechenzentrums-Leute,
Netzwerkleute, irgendwas IT-mäßig
ist gar nichts da bei euch.
Es ist so.
Das ist so. Wer das Video gesehen hat,
weiß, dass ich kein Schnitzel geklaut hab,
Chat.
Warum sollte ich Schnitzel klauen?
Dann mach ich lieber Pepo Burn Money und kauf mir einen Schnitzel.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was hält dich davon ab, ins Büro zu gehen?
Das ist ein gutes Subreddit
Das habe ich auch
ge...
gejoined auf Reddit.
Service, der...
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab gerne
damals bei unserem Support gesessen.
Ich hab Jahre im gleichen Büro
wie unser Support gehockt.
Wobei das kein Service-Desk war,
in dem Sinn. Das war
so
Network-Operation-mäßig.
Also die haben quasi den ganzen Tag monitoren geguckt
und bei Tickets eskaliert
und sowas. Die kannten sich auch
ein bisschen mit Linux und Technik aus.
Ich hab da super gerne gehockt.
Aber so, aber
Service Desk, wo dann irgendwie
die Sekretärin
vom Chef anruft und sagt,
ah, wie krieg ich denn in Word,
mein WordArt um 60% gedreht?
Da hätt ich wahrscheinlich auch keinen Bock,
das mitzubekommen.
Oh, das ist
Sadgear, ja, das stimmt.
Chat, ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Wir haben
bald
wieder jährliches
Teambuilding-Event.
Zwei Tage.
Ich glaube ja,
das wird wieder ein wenig
Painz-Champ.
Wobei man
fairer halber sagen muss,
den Tower of Power haben wir schon gemacht.
Den machen wir bestimmt nicht noch mehr.
Chat, musste schon mal einer von euch
den Tower of Power machen?
Ist auch so ein nerviges Teamspiel.
Ich muss aber sagen, der Fairness halber, so schlecht wie die Teambuilding-Maßnahmen bei meinem vorvorletzten Arbeitgeber sind die nicht.
Die sind erträglich, ja. Außerdem gibt es immer gutes Zeug und viel zu fressen.
Power of Power, pass mal auf.
Power of Power.
Ja.
Moment, wir müssen mal in den Dark Mode, nicht den Dark Mode, hier den Night Mode.
Das hier ist der Tower of Power.
Guckt, da steht man dann so und die Leute sind wie auf diesem Foto natürlich super glücklich.
Logisch, wer solche tollen Teamspiele macht, kann ja nichts anderes als glücklich sein.
Gibt's da, gibt's, hier gibt's Bilder, guck mal.
Leute, hier, ja?
Da musst du, da musst du so Türmchen bauen.
Da kriegst du so verschiedene
Klötzchen
So einen Kran
Der an so einem Ding fest ist
Und halt Seile
Und da müssen die Leute
Zusammenarbeiten, dass um den Kran
Operaten, hier guck da unten hängt das
Und so fonst das
Das sind so beliebte
Das sind so beliebte Spiele
Bei so Teambuilding Events
Was ich mich ja bei diesen Events
Immer frage ist
gibt es wirklich
wissenschaftliche
Untersuchungen dazu,
dass solche Events was bringen?
Oder ist das nur so
Pseudopsychologie immer?
Genauso wie dieses mit den
Du bist Farbe Blau, Du bist Farbe Rot,
Du bist Farbe Grün. Das ist ja auch nur so Pseudopsychologie.
Und noch viel mehr,
was ich noch viel spannender finde,
Gibt es Leute, die richtig Spaß an solchen Spielen haben?
Also, außer dem Trainer jetzt.
Der Trainer hat zwar jetzt nicht direkt Spaß dran, aber der Trainer hat Spaß dran,
weil er wahrscheinlich massig Kohle kriegt für solche Events.
Aber gibt es wirklich Leute, die sagen, yeah man, Tower of Power, endlich mal wieder.
Aber ich gehe sogar
semi-gerle hin, ja, und das heißt
schon was, auf unsere Teambuilding-Events.
Also ich freue mich insofern
drauf, dass es
dort wahrscheinlich wieder riesiges Buffet
gibt. Massive,
massive, witzig,
vor fünf Minuten habe ich noch erzählt, ich will wieder
ein bisschen mehr abnehmen, aber egal.
Messe fressen, zwischendurch fressen, Häppchen Snacks fressen, morgens fressen, abends fressen, Kaffee fressen.
Also, das ist immer das Beste auf diesen Events.
Und was auch ganz nett ist, mit dem einen oder anderen ein bisschen schwätzen.
Das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Nicht vom Tower auf Power.
So.
Chat, was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir uns noch ein, zwei kleine Videos angucken?
Weil ich muss...
Oh, was ist das?
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt nicht aufmachen.
Kokona.
Ich wollte eigentlich das hier aufmachen.
Was verdient ein Kraftwerker?
ETF.
Gucken wir uns noch ein, zwei kleine Videos an.
Weil ich habe jetzt seit
40 Minuten
mein Abendessen hier stehen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger, weil ich habe einen Fehler gemacht, Freund.
Bin heimgekommen, habe mich direkt
auf mein Fahrrad gehockt.
YouTube-Zwischüss-Algorithmus.
Okay.
Ich bin heimgekommen, habe mich direkt, also im Endeffekt habe ich eigentlich nur mein Hose ausgezogen, mein Hemd ausgezogen, Zwift gestartet, also hier nicht Zwift, Zwift, Zwift gestartet und habe mich auf mein Fahrrad gehockt und bin so knapp 35 Minuten gefahren.
und ich hab nix, ich hab
normalerweise, bevor ich anfange Sport zu machen
esse ich immer noch ein bisschen Banane
davor
aber ging wunderbar
Fahrrad ordentlich getreten, ordentlich
Power reingetreten für 35 Minuten
dann umgezogen
noch knapp 30 Minuten
Joggen gewesen und
mir ist dann aber nach der Hälfte der Joggingzeit
aufgefallen, fuck, du kriegst langsam echt
Hunger
Und falls es jemand schon mal erlebt hat
Wenn man Sport macht und dabei Hunger kriegt
Ist es meist eine ganz schlechte Kombination
Weil das heißt meistens innerhalb der nächsten 10 Minuten
Oder so kann man nicht mehr
Aber zum Glück war die Hälfte schon rum
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich brutal Hunger
Und müsste jetzt endlich mal mein Toastbrot futtern
So
Was haben wir denn hier schönes
Ich hab mir letztens ein Video gespeichert
Weil ich mir gedacht habe
Das müssen wir zusammen
Im Stream angucken
Lasst mich mal kurz checken
Es kann aber auch sein
Dass wir uns schon
Angeguckt haben
Ah das haben wir uns schon angeguckt
Der Informatiker bei Lufthansa
War das, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt
Welchen Mini-PC
Für Proxmox und OpenCore kaufen?
Das ist eigentlich fast egal
Wichtig ist, wie viel RAM soll es sein
I build a home data center
Na dann, zeig mal her
Ich lässe da ja immer gerne ein bisschen über die Setups
Von anderen Leuten
Und bei meinem Setup halt auch irgendwie
optisch
stark verbesserungswürdig ist
und auch von der Hardware.
Ich mach kurz die Musik aus.
Was jetzt?
Ist mein Browser jetzt gefreezed oder was?
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Mein Browser ist gefreezed?
Oder auch nicht.
Ne, an den vielen Tabs kann das nicht liegen.
RAM voll.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn mein RAM auch nur ansatzweise voll wäre.
Dann hätte es sich nämlich richtig gelohnt, 64GB zu kaufen.
Ich bin aber aus heutiger Sicht wirklich froh 64Gig gekauft zu haben
Weil 64Gig kannst du dir halt heute nicht mehr leisten gescheit
Wir haben doch eben geguckt 1700 Euro
Na gut okay das war Server ECC RAM
Aber 64 sind besser als 32
Oder nicht
Okay zeig mal her
Oh nein Piss nicht sehen
Da schreit es so rum. Ich hoffe, da schreit nicht weiter, dann kann ich mir das nicht angucken.
Hey, das kenne ich.
Das ist Dins, das ist ein...
Warte mal.
Das, was man da unten gesehen hat, das sind, glaube ich, Genpro-Gehäuse.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor, auf jeden Fall.
Okay.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Werbung! Ah!
Chat!
Jetzt fahr ich ein bisschen...
Chat, es funktioniert wunderbar.
Also, ihr habt gerade das Pop-Up gesehen.
Wenn ihr interessiert seid
an Storage, Ukraine, Nassus
und generell guten Preisen für Festplatten,
dann geht
bei mir auf den Channel...
geht bei mir auf den Channel
und klickt diesen Link an
oder Ausrufezeichen Ukraine,
Ausrufezeichen Seagate oder Ausrufezeichen
Alternate im Chat.
Dann gibt es den Link, könnt ihr euch das Ganze
angucken und wohlgemerkt,
die Preise gelten nur über meinen Link.
Sonst gibt es das nicht, sonst ist es teurer.
Exzellent.
Irgendwie kommt da nichts bei rum hier.
Was ist das?
Ich will...
Das ist auch wieder so ein Techno-Tim-Setup.
30 Milliarden Dinger.
Ohne dass er damit...
Mich würde mal interessieren, ob er noch zeigt, was er damit jetzt eigentlich betreibt.
Okay, ich habe da schon Glasfaserkabel gerade gesehen.
Was ist das? Dokumentenschredder oder eine Klimaanlage?
Okay, Air Conditioning.
drei minecraft server das müssen das müssen aber 1000 player server seine
dass du das dafür alles braucht
mich würde interessieren was er denn jetzt eigentlich
postet weiß man aber nicht das ist natürlich nicht so nicht so aussagekräftig dann gucken
mal was der kraftwerker verdient warum spart er jeden jeden monat 1500 euro kriegt da kriegt
er quasi mitarbeiter rabatt beim strom oder kein sub da gelassen dafür kann es ja mein
RevLink anklicken.
Er betreibt
eine Hosting-Plattform für
Minecraft-Server.
Ach so.
Ups.
Ja, das ist ja schon wieder
was anderes.
Wenn er eine
Hosting-Plattform für Minecraft-Server
betreibt, dann ist das wieder was anderes.
Ich würde mir gerne diese Hosting-Plattform angucken,
aber irgendwie geht mein
meine History nicht mehr auf.
Gucken wir mal kurz hier. History.
History.
History Page.
I build the home data.
Ich will mal gucken, vielleicht hat er
einen Link zu seiner Minecraft Hosting.
My free Minecraft Playhosting.
Oh, das ist
eine gute Domain.
Das ist, Leute, was sagt ihr?
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Domain.
Play.hosting.
Das ist nice.
Da hat er schnell zugeschlagen,
die zu bekommen.
Hä?
Play.hosting.
Das sieht sogar relativ professional aus.
Ja.
Ist es WordPress?
Hä?
Ich glaube nicht.
Oder?
es ist
Lillipad GG.
Das sieht nach manuellem
erstelltem HTML
aus und kein
WordPress-Gedöns.
Interessant.
Also für das, dass er das Hobby-mäßig
bei sich daheim betreibt, was ich mich
jetzt nur frage ist,
wie macht er das denn mit der Internet-Anbindung
daheim?
Wobei auf der anderen Seite,
wenn du Glasfaser daheim hast,
Gigabit.
Geekdown 500 Mbit ab.
Kannst du schon einiges mit hosten.
Wahrscheinlich darfst du offiziell nix hosten.
Laut den Terms of Service von deinem Provider.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Aber ansonsten können kannst du das.
Und was kostet da so ein Minecraft Server?
Sieht man nicht.
Geil.
Moment.
Yes, it's 100% free.
WTF?
Ja, gut.
Das heißt,
der betreibt das,
um im Endeffekt was Gutes
für die Menschheit zu tun.
Das ist doch
ehrenwert.
Ja.
Okay.
Dann schauen wir uns ihn hier mal an.
Kann ich nämlich was bei futtern.
Mit einem Mausklick wird es auf einmal unglaublich laut oder warm.
Einfach überwältigend.
Oh, da wird wieder zensiert.
Das ist ein bisschen scheiße, das erzögert sich alles.
Ich komme mit der Verantwortung gut klar und werde auch dementsprechend gut vergütet.
Das machen die für Strom, oder?
Dass du da nicht richtig dran musst.
Hi, ich bin Flo, bin 23 Jahre, arbeite als geprüfter Kraftwerker im Herzen von Berlin.
Und ich nehme euch heute mit auf eine Spätschicht.
Wir sind jetzt im Heizkraftwerk Mitte. Hier erzeugen wir Strom und Wärme für Berlin.
An diesem Standort stehen zwei große Gasturbinen und eine Dampfturbine.
Ich bin Operator oder Anlagenfahrer, wäre das deutsche Wort dafür.
Das heißt, ich bediene, überwache, kontrolliere, steuere alle Anlagen hier im Kraftwerk.
Ihr habt großes Glück, wir fahren heute unsere zweite Maschine an.
Ich glaube, heute wird schon ein spannender Tag.
Mahlzeit.
Schönen Feierabend, bis morgen.
Also unsere Arbeitsbereiche sind aufgeteilt.
Ungefähr so
sah das in diesem Network
Operations Center
aus, wo ich
dabei gehockt hab, beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Ich war nicht
in dem Team, ich hab im gleichen Büro gehockt.
Und es war auch so.
Die hatten auch so halbschräge Sache
und hier vorne, also da wo die Kamera
ist, quasi eine Monitorwand.
Ich sitze jetzt hier mit dem
einen Kollegen, wir überwachen
die zwei Gasturbinen, die wir hier haben und die eine Dampfturbine und alle Aggregate, die dazu gehören.
Ich arbeite in einem rollenden oder rotierenden Fünfschichtsystem.
Das heißt, wir haben fünf Schichten und jede Schicht macht früh, spät und Nachtschicht.
Auf einen Ton ist aufgeteilt von fünf Wochen.
Ich arbeite in der ersten Woche, Montag bis Freitag, Frühschicht.
Dann habe ich das Wochenende frei.
Dann habe ich dreimal Nachtschicht, zwei Tage frei, das Wochenende Frühschicht.
Dann habe ich Montag, Dienstag Spätschicht.
Dann einen Tag frei und am Donnerstag vier Nachtschichten.
Dann am Ende arbeite ich nochmal fünf Spätschichten von Mittwoch bis Sonntag.
Aber das ist genauso kompliziert.
Ich liebe den Schichtbetrieb, sonst würde ich nicht auf Schicht arbeiten.
Boah, Schichtbetrieb ist richtig räudig.
Gerade wenn du switchst und dann auf einmal irgendwann abends auf die Arbeit fahren musst und sowas.
Ich liebe es, zu spät zu kommen, mal auszuschlafen bis um 11 oder um 10.
Bei jedem, wie es gefällt, ja.
Jetzt haben wir auch gerade Ende der Heizperiode und Beginn der Revisionsphase im Kraftwerk.
Gerade im Mai, im Sommer und zu Beginn der Heizperiode dann, also im September,
Oktober haben wir viel zu tun, viel an den Anlagen zu machen.
Die Zuschläge sind wirklich nicht verkehrt, ja.
Du musst, glaube ich, bei Schichtzulingen,
gibt es auch, musst du gar keine Steuern drauf bezahlen
oder weniger Steuern drauf bezahlen, irgendwie so.
Habe ich das damals mitgeklickt von unseren Leuten.
Ich bin auch noch ziemlich jung und die Schaltberechtigung habe ich auch erst seit einem Jahr, anderthalb Jahren.
Und dann ist jede Schalthandlung immer was Eigenes.
Und ja, immer interessant, aber man hat auch immer ein bisschen Respekt vor der Größe.
Ja, da gibt es ein paar Videos, die will ich mir jetzt nicht mit euch angucken.
Aus Indien und so teilweise.
wo die Leute
an irgendwelchen
Hochspannungsinstallationen
rumbasteln
und nicht so gut trainiert sind wie er.
Leute,
die zerlegt es teilweise richtig.
Also,
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Das ist nicht so wie
einer aus Versehen mal
an irgendwas gegriffen, was in der Steckdose steckt.
Das soll auch nicht sein.
Das ist auch, by the way,
das ist auch lebensgefährlich.
weil es nicht hingehen der max hat gesagt das macht nächsten finger in die steckdose stecken
das auch lebensgefährlich aber da schmilzt noch nicht instant metall
und da gibt es videos wie gesagt wirklich anhand der leute hätte ich gesagt irgendwo indien oder
so oder afghanistan keine ahnung landwirt vielleicht mit sicherheit nicht so hoch
gehalten wird.
Und da habe ich ein Video gesehen, das ist auf Twitter
zufällig. Da ist einer
in so eine Hochspannungsinstallation
gegangen, hat da was gemacht.
Auf einmal hat es
Funken gegeben.
Es hat ganze
Metallstäbe
geschmolzen.
Und quasi Staub,
Staub, also quasi
heißer Metallstaub,
ist dadurch entstanden.
und das will ich euch jetzt nicht näher beschreiben,
aber der Typ, als der da rausgekommen ist,
ich gehe stark davon aus,
weiter als 5 Meter konnte er nicht mehr laufen.
Dann war er hinüber.
Also, der lief nur noch auf Adrenalin.
Der Rest war schon dead.
Also, das ist echt nicht ohne solche Dinger da.
Aber wir sind jetzt hier, alle Rückmeldungen sind da.
Ich werde jetzt nochmal schnell oben in der Warte anrufen
und die Kollegen fragen, ob alles soweit sauber ist.
Okay, alles klar, dann kommen wir hoch.
Ich habe schon enorm viel Verantwortung
aufgrund der
Anlagenbauweisen, wie die miteinander
kommunizieren, sind die Anlagen hochkomplex.
Schaust du NSFL-Videos?
Ich musste gerade googeln, was das heißt.
Ich schaue mittlerweile
bewusst, wenn ich im Vorfeld
weiß, das ist irgendwie so
ein disturbing Video-Content.
Ich schaue das bewusst mittlerweile nicht.
Wie ich noch jung war
und man sich gerne nochmal geschockt hat.
Da habe ich so einen Mist geguckt.
Mittlerweile gucke ich das absichtlich
nicht mehr. Also wenn irgendwo was
eingeblendet wird und ich kann es im Vorfeld
schon ahnen, dass das irgendwie so
disturbing Content ist, dann gucke ich es nicht.
Weil den Scheiß will ich mir nicht geben.
Kommt, wenn man
schon mehrere falsche Mäusenklick hintereinander macht,
dass die Firma dann 100.000 Euro kostet.
Kevin, wir machen jetzt die Pumpenabschaltung, ja?
Ich will keine Links dazu im Chat haben.
Die Pumpe dreht jetzt hoch.
Jetzt, merkt ihr?
Das ist total cool.
Ich habe wirklich einen perfekten Takerwisch.
So einen Pumpenwechsel macht man so selten.
Dann hört man das noch runter, das ist wirklich erste Sahne.
Schön.
Das ist schön. Das ist ein Gänsehaut.
Meine Ausbildung war sehr breit gefächert.
Also EBT, das ist jetzt keine Verpflichtung, Kraftwerker machen zu müssen.
Damit kann man eigentlich heutzutage...
Was ich aber auch wieder interessant zu sehen, interessant finde,
der scheint ja auch den ganzen Tag was zu schaffen.
Also nicht wie die Excel-schreibende Marketingfrau, die sie da mal hatten.
Der macht auch was für sein Geld.
In jede Richtung gehen, Solar, ganz normal, Elektriker, Bau...
Und es ist auch noch gefährlich, S-Fuck, wenn du nicht aufpasst.
Ich wollte in der Industrie bleiben, bei der Firma bleiben, das war mir wichtig.
Wir schalten jetzt die Aggregate ein. Das machen wir jetzt ein bisschen früher, damit dann die Maschine auch pünktlich, wie mit einem Lastverteiler vereinbart, am Netz sein kann.
Hier wird es gleich grün und der Strom steigt sehr stark an.
Der Motor sollte jetzt eigentlich grün werden, also in Betrieb gehen. Wir wissen gerade selber nicht, warum er nicht reagiert.
Wir machen das gleiche wie immer.
Aber wir kriegen gerade...
Purple Cloud sagt, solche Visualisierungen
sind leider mein Job.
Du machst solche Übersichten.
Da würde mich immer
interessieren, auf welchem Betriebssystem
läuft diese Software?
Und in was ist sie programmiert?
Ich würde tippen
Java, Windows.
Leider.
Was mir lieber wäre,
wäre Linux-Java.
Aber
ist es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und die Dinger sind so alt,
es bin auch Kobol.
Keine Reaktion
vom Motor, dass er
an ist.
Ich gebe jetzt dem Start erstmal nochmal ein Ein und danach
aus und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann die Funktionsgruppe
nochmal aus.
Das ist jetzt scheiße, das zögert sich aus.
C und Visual Basic.
MonkaS.
Visual Basic.
Ey, das Ding ist bestimmt so alt.
Das läuft noch mit Visual Basic 6, oder?
Visual Basic Script.
Was ist denn das?
So was wie VBA, oder was?
Das sieht ja richtig...
Das sieht schon kacke aus.
Moment, Moment.
VBS und dann
HTML?
WTF, was bin ich hier sehend?
Notepad++?
Internet Explorer?
Was zum...
Was geht denn hier ab?
Auch Kackseide.
Moment, Moment, die machen gerade Website mit VBScript.
Ja gut, so ein Scheiß funktioniert nur im Internet Explorer, das ist schon mal klar.
Microsoft hat in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten echt schon viel Zeug da verbrochen.
Ganz wichtig, immer ruhig bleiben, Ruhe bewahren und zu überlegen, woher kommt jetzt dieser Fehler.
Geh für die Schaltanlage.
Schnell, ja.
Ich gucke jetzt hier am Monitor, wo irgendwelche Meldungen noch anstehen, merkwürdige Signale, die wir so nicht kennen, die vielleicht mit den Meldungen oben jetzt zusammenhängen könnten.
Aber ich kann leider nicht. Wisst ihr was der auch noch hat? Der muss sich ja auch die komplette Schicht auch noch konzentrieren.
Das ist nicht, man gammelt ein bisschen vorm Rechner rum
und er hat da ein sehr hohes eigenes Interesse daran sich zu konzentrieren. Weil wenn der sich nicht konzentriert
und an irgendwelchen Hochspannungsdingern rummacht,
dann schmilzt er einfach.
Wir werden uns jetzt auch ein bisschen nervös, weil die Zeit läuft uns jetzt davon.
Wir sollen ja pünktlich am Netz sein.
Kommst du klar?
Okay.
Gut, wir gehen wieder hoch.
Ah, okay.
Tom, Tom, Tom.
Ja.
Warte mal, Kevin hat gerade ein Rückmeldung bekommen von Einstein.
Kommt mit.
Hast du schon?
Das war es schon. Habt ihr es gehört? Läuft.
Es hat geknallt.
Ich stand gerade eben noch auf lokal.
Das heißt, wir hatten keinen Zugriff von oben auf diesen Leistungsschalter.
Wir haben uns danach auch gefragt, wieso steht denn jetzt dieser Leistungsschalter so da?
Obwohl es nirgends so vermerkt worden ist, nicht angesprochen ist.
wieder passieren also hier sehen wir jetzt im motor ist grün stromaufnahme
ist deutlich gestiegen ist sehr gut also jetzt geht es zu den leitprogrammen im
betrieb wo jetzt und die maschine ist am netz um 16 uhr 54 netzschaltung hat man
chat und gab es kannst du dich daran erinnern als ich von der arbeitsstelle
mit active directory erzählt habe als ich mich beworben habe konnte ich noch
kein active directory ich kann mich dunkel daran erinnern ja
Details weiß ich nicht mehr, aber ich kann mich hier in Kombination mit deinem Namen
und Active Directory, kann ich mich da dunkel dran erinnern.
Und was gibt's da neues?
Wir haben jetzt die restliche Zeit, die genügt uns, um die Maschine so schnell zu belasten,
dass sie zu ihrer gewünschten Uhrzeit auch die gewünschte Leistung erreicht hat.
Das ist doch ein Traum.
Könnte man so sagen, ja.
Boah, super.
Fertig?
Bitteschön.
Danke.
Danke, danke.
Wir bestellen in der Spätpflicht oftmals, weil es von der Zeit her immer gut passt zum Essen.
Guten Appetit.
Worauf ich immer so achte, sind vor allen Dingen Dinge, die sich verändern.
Also Gerüche, man soll immer mit allen Sinnen durch die Anlage gehen.
Die Nase, die Ohren, die Augen natürlich.
Oder auch fühlen, wenn beispielsweise irgendwas besonders kalt ist oder besonders heiß ist, was im normalen Betrieb eigentlich nicht so ist.
Wenn du irgendwie dran greifst und es bitzelt, ist es wahrscheinlich auch schlecht.
Sieht gut aus. Kontrollier die andere Seite nochmal.
Mein Bruttogehalt setzt sich zusammen aus drei Bausteinen.
Das ist erstens mein Tarifgehalt nach Haustarif.
Das sind 4.500 Euro brutto.
Dort kommt eine Leistungszulage von 30 Euro brutto
und eine Schichtzulage für die Arbeit im Schichtsystem von 180 Euro brutto obendrauf.
So wenig für die Schicht?
Somit lande ich dann auf einem Gesamt...
Ja gut, aber für die Schicht Einsätze gibt es ja dann auch noch mehr, ja?
Von circa 4.700 Euro.
Von meinem Netto werden mir verschiedene Sachen abgezogen, darunter Essensaufgaben im Betriebsrestaurant.
Ich hätte ehrlich gesagt, da verdiene ich ein bisschen mehr.
Ich habe einen Beitrag für diesen Monat und die betriebliche Altersversorgung.
Diese wird sehr attraktiv bezuschusst, je nach eingezahltem Anteil von mir.
Auf mein gesetzliches Netto kommen dann nochmal meine Schichtzulagen aus dem vorherigen Monat obendrauf als Nachverrechnung.
Oh, Ecos schreibt, ähm, hat eine Absage bekommen.
Ja, kann man nix machen.
Go next.
Haben sie den Grund genannt? Warum sie nicht wollten?
Der ist 23.
1.000 bis 1.200 Euro netto und somit lade ich dann bei einem gesamten Netto von 3.700 Euro.
Und wenn jetzt abgelöst von den anderen Kollegen...
Das ist doch schon okay.
...dann bei einem gesamten Netto von 3.200 Euro...
Ach, das ist das, was er verdient hat mit Schicht und so. Ja, das kommt jetzt schon eher hin.
...netto und somit lade ich dann bei einem gesamten Netto von 3.700 Euro.
Ja, das ist dann schon ganz ordentlich.
Wir werden jetzt abgelöst von den anderen Kollegen, die jetzt hier den Arbeitsplatz übernehmen und die Anlage auch übernehmen.
Oh, na dann erzähl doch mal.
Also, du siehst die Meldefolge.
Dann haben wir die Fernnetzwasser-Umwärtspumpe 2.
Habt ihr wieder umgetauscht?
Genau, haben getauscht auf die 1.
Dann hatten wir heute Startprobleme, weil der Leistungsschiff...
Ich meine, es ist halt ein gefährlicher Job.
Auch einen, wo du dich konzentrieren musst und einen Plan von haben musst mit Schichtarbeit.
Ist ja auch gut, dass das gut bezahlt wird.
Der Schalter stand auf lokal vom Ergasverdichter.
Und dann ist mein Zettel eigentlich schon abgegrast.
Cool.
Ja, dann geh doch nach Hause.
Mach ich auch.
Gut, eine ruhige Schicht wünsch ich.
Hat die für die Schicht?
Gut.
Ja, doch.
Wir hatten schöne Arbeiten da mit dabei.
Auch eine kleine Störung, aber haben wir gut weggemanagt.
Alles, würde ich mal so sagen.
Ein Jahresbrutto setzt sich zusammen aus einem weiteren 13. Monatsgehalt und einer Erfolgsbezahlung.
Also Chad, ich muss sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Die sind eindeutig nicht agile genug.
Die machen kein Daily Scrum, keine Retrospektive, kein Planning, kein Review.
Wie kann das überhaupt funktionieren?
... Heiligung im April.
Diese ist ungefähr auch ein weiteres 14. Gehalt.
Damit komme ich auf ein Jahresbrutto von um die 64.000 Euro.
und da sind die Zulagen noch nicht mal mit eingerechnet.
Luft nach oben ist immer cool, dass man weiß, man ist noch nicht da, wo man eigentlich hin will
und hat immer Ehrgeiz, sich weiterzubilden, fortzubilden, am Ball zu bleiben.
Ich hätte schon gerne Personalverantwortung später.
Gut, nun bin ich noch sehr, sehr jung, muss auch noch viel lernen, ruhiger werden
und dann denke ich, steht dem Schichtleiter nicht mehr so viel entgegen.
Nice.
Ich betreibe jetzt für das Leasing aktuell 450.
15.000 kilometer also ich bin mal beim kollegen mitgefahren er hatte auch so ein
auto also ich weiß nur dass es halt gleich gleich hersteller ist
den fand ich eigentlich ganz nice ihr wisst ich bin nicht der große auto
fan ich habe jetzt auch kein fettes auto oder sowas aber da wo ich da mitgefahren
muss schon sagen war ganz angenehm er hatte auch innen drin so komische
beleuchtung und sowas dreieinhalb jahre liebe auto fahren und vor allen dingen
auch elektrisches Auto fahren. Das macht mir viel Spaß. Wenn man so jung ist und doch so
verhältnismäßig viel Geld verdient, dann gönnt man sich das.
Kleiner Roomtour. Also hier ist die C-Cab.
Du fragst dich, ob er für das Inbetriebnehmen des Motors einen Change im Cap eingereicht hat.
Also zumindest mal ein Change Workflow im Ticketsystem hat es ja dafür gebraucht.
Alles sehr klein, aber...
Und außerdem ist ja der aktuelle Sprint noch gar nicht gestartet. Ohne Sprint kann er auch nichts machen.
Fein. Also ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen. Wir wohnen in einer kleinen Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung.
Aktuell sind wir noch nicht bereit, viel mehr für die Miete auszugeben, weil von der Größe her passt das auch.
Und dann geben wir das Geld lieber für Reisen oder schöne Urlaube aus oder sparen es lieber.
Letztes Jahr im Dezember waren wir in der Karibik und in Südamerika. 2024 waren wir auf Bali.
Ich bin alles gut, der macht mit der Kohle auch was
Ja
Nicht so langweilig wie bei mir
Einfach
Alles in ETF
Naja, nicht alles, aber das meiste in ETF
Und gut ist
Ich bin halt so ein richtiges Kellerkind
Ich will nicht groß in Urlaub fahren
Ich
Ich hab keinen Bock
Großartig irgendwie
Hobbys nachzugehen, die teuer wären
Das teuerste Hobby, was ich hab ist
fahrrad fahren und da habe ich ein fahrrad gekauft vor zwei jahren für 3000 euro und das hält jetzt
auch erst einmal werbung werbung chatte wer auf der suche ist nach einem energiesparende
nass und günstigen festplatten kann es bei mir auf den channel gucken da findet ihr einen link
oder Ausrufezeichen Seagate, Ausrufezeichen Alternate, Aufrufezeichen Ukraine im Chat.
Da gibt es einen Link und die Preise gelten nur über meinen Link.
Könnt ihr euch das Ganze mal angucken.
Zweieinhalb Wochen, dann sind wir jedes Jahr im Skiurlaub in Norwegen.
Da spielt dann eigentlich nicht so die große Rolle, da sind wir im Urlaub.
Das gönnen wir uns einfach und sagen, ja, dafür gehen wir arbeiten.
Ich spare auch unglaublich gern mein Geld, investiere mein Geld viel.
600 Euro von meinem Netto gehen in ETFs.
Sehr gut.
Du liest bestimmt auch Finanzen auf Reddit.
200 Euro in Aktien und 150 Euro in Kryptowährungen.
Ein langfristiges Spazier gibt es eigentlich nicht, aber das klingt jetzt doof, man kann nie genug haben.
Ja, ist so.
Aber die 100.000 würde ich schon gerne mal sehen, auf jeden Fall.
Und wenn man ganz groß denkt, mit 50, 60 auch gerne die eine Million.
Und dann in Rente gehen?
Ja.
Ich würde mich jetzt nur nochmal an den PC setzen und den Abend ausklingen lassen,
bevor ich dann so eine Stunde maximal auch ins Bett gehe, weil ich echt müde bin vom Tag.
Du guckst, lohnt sich das? Lohnt sich dein Job?
Ja, mein Job lohnt sich auf jeden Fall für mich. Ich liebe die Schichtarbeit.
Du bist ein sympathischer Kerl.
Unterschiedliche Arbeitszeiten und die Dynamik an meinem Job.
Ich bin super zufrieden und würde aktuell auch nichts anderes machen wollen.
Und wenigstens gibt es auch angemessen Kohle.
So viele Tabs?
Wieso?
Ich habe hier Tabs, ich habe da Tabs
und ich habe hier auch noch Tabs.
Das sind nicht alle.
Ja, zu meinen genauen Vermögensverhältnissen will ich nichts sagen.
Ich kann sagen, ich bin kein Milliardär.
Ich bin auch kein Multimillionär.
Also für mich sind
80 Millionen
viel Geld.
Aber
für die Bank anscheinend nicht.
Indische Rupien.
Ich hatte mal ein YouTube-Abo
in indischen Rupien.
Tabs sind wie Geldkammer,
nicht genug.
Ja, also, Fun Fact,
wenn die das vorher nicht mitgekriegt haben,
wir hatten letztens bei uns im Projekt
Daily, hat einer erzählt,
ja, einer unserer Partner,
die testen jetzt auch mal,
quasi, Kryptowerte
zu transferieren von einer Blockchain
auf die andere,
falls mal eine Blockchain
quasi abgestellt wird, und die haben da jetzt
für den Test eine Transaktion gestartet
mit 80 Millionen.
Da musste ich auch nochmal blöd nachfragen.
Moment.
Die hauen 80 Millionen raus
für einen einfachen Test?
Ja, ist so.
Ja, klar.
Die haben es ja auch.
Bank macht halt Bankdinge.
Juckt die nicht.
Wir haben sogar, auch was witzig ist, wir haben sogar eine Policy eingerichtet,
dass du unter bestimmten Bedingungen, also bestimmte Usergruppe, bestimmte Blockchain, da darfst du keine Transaktionen machen unter 100.000 Euro.
Steht da wirklich drin?
Größer 100.000.
Also mit Kleinkram wird sich da nicht rumgeschlagen
Größer 100.000
Die schmeißen da eh krass mit Kohle um sich
Also ich würde mich für so einen Test ja auch freiwillig zur Verfügung stellen
Oh, Updates, ja wir haben auch schon eine halbe Stunde nicht mehr geupdatet
Also sie können mir gerne zum Test 80 Millionen überweisen
Chat, wenn die mir zum Test 80 Millionen überweisen,
dann kriegt jeder von euch, der jetzt da ist,
kriegt von euch einen 16 GB RAM-Riegel.
Müsste knapp reichen.
Im August geht es los mit 30 in die Physie-Ausbildung.
Exzellent.
Warum machst du jetzt Physie?
Kein Bock mehr auf den alten Job
Schlechte Joblage im alten Job
Kein Bock mehr
Wolltest du schon immer machen
Konntest nicht
Warum
Ich meine ich finde das gut
Ich war auch schon ein bisschen älter als ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe
Ich dachte ja auch immer es ist nicht zu spät
ECC
Für 80 Millionen würde ich sagen
gönne ich gönne ich euch auch etc ram
und es ist schon immer machen da ist dankeschön für den zap das schön machst
du nach wie sie hast du voll kann sagen machst du anwendungsentwicklung oder
fachinformatik systemindikation systemindikation was du weißt was hier
passieren kann ist dass du in der berufsschule ein bisschen blöd
angeguckt wirst. Ich war ja auch schon ein bisschen
älter damals.
Bei den ganzen 16, 17-Jährigen.
Da wurde ich auch ein bisschen blöd
angeguckt mit ein paar 20.
Aber wen juckt's?
Du möchtest eine Umschulung machen?
Ey, ich muss euch jetzt mal dazu sagen, also
wenn ihr es machen wollt,
sicher. Aber wenn ihr es nur
macht, weil ihr denkt, danach gibt es die fette Kohle
in dem Bereich oder die suchen unendlich Leute
und man findet easy einen Job, der fette Kohle gibt.
Das ist aktuell nicht so.
Ja.
Ja, aktuell ist es gerade für Einsteiger schwierig.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
wie das wird,
wenn die feststellen,
dass man mit reinem Vibe-Coding doch nicht so geile Sachen machen kann.
Wie viele AI-Versteher-Jobs dann entstehen,
die dann quasi prompten und versuchen zu verstehen,
was da gestrickt wurde und das auch ein bisschen verbessern und ergänzen noch.
Willst du mal meine Bachelor-Aber? Über was hast du geschrieben?
Also ehrlich gesagt
Ich würde jetzt nur aus Nettigkeit sagen
Ja, zeig her
Weil ich kenn mich
Da will ich schon mal ehrlich sein, ja
Ich kenn mich, ich les
Ich bin ultra faul
Ich les das wahrscheinlich eh nicht
Was jetzt nicht explizit an deiner Bachelorarbeit liegt
Aber ich bin faul
Wenn es nichts ist, was mich persönlich brennend interessiert
oder ich aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen lesen muss,
bin ich zu faul, irgendwelche Sachen anzugucken.
Naja, es ist ja nicht so, dass es gar keine Jobs für Einsteiger gibt.
Und je nachdem, was du vorher gemacht hast, ist es vielleicht danach immer noch besser.
Weiß man ja nicht.
Du kannst übrigens auch verkürzen
Du musst nicht komplett 3 Jahre machen
Was auch ziemlich easy ist
Das wichtigste bei der Ausbildung ist ja eh nicht
Dass du Ahnung hast von deinem Job
Also für die Prüfung
Sondern dass du Prüfungen im Vorfeld übst
Am Ende ist es natürlich schon wichtig, dass du Ahnung hast
Weil das wird auf der Arbeit gebraucht
Aber für die Ausbildung selbst
Und die Abschlussprüfung ist egal, ob du Ahnung hast oder nicht
Da musst du nur wissen, wie du die Abschlussprüfung
Am besten erledigst
Das ist natürlich auch bitter
Der Flozan schreibt
Uns zwingen die Führungskräfte demnächst
Die Vibe-Code-Anwendungen, die sie programmiert haben
Bereitzustellen
Wenn die das Vibe-Coded haben
Soll ich mal raten
Das ist bestimmt eine Python-Anwendung, weil Führungskräfte gehört haben, Python ist voll angesagter Shit.
Oder?
Das ist seine Bachelorarbeit.
Okay, komm, wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen Werbung hier für Max Stahlmann.
Seine Bachelor...
Bugatti AR Experience.
Das ist ein Video.
Okay.
Wo ist die Bachelorarbeit?
Ja, das stimmt, die Webseite ist nicht hübsch, aber das ist jetzt egal.
Quatsch.
Wenn hier was gededost wird, dann ist das höchstens mal ein Ref-Link.
Kommt nicht auf blöde Ideen, Chat.
Ich will euch jetzt nicht irgendwie, nicht, dass einer sagt, der Max hat jetzt angestifft und es ist Alternate-Down.
Hört mal bloß auf.
Lickstee Dossen
Aha
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Ach du kannst
Ach so
Das ist für die Leute
Die gerne mal live
Sehen wollen
Wie das so ist
so ein Auto zu haben.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Das Problem ist glaube ich nur,
dass kaum einer so ein VR-Ding hat,
mit dem er draußen rumrennen kann.
Aber bestimmt ganz cool
für welche, die so Autos
verkaufen. Da kannst du sagen,
hier setzen sie mal auf, können sie sich virtuell
durchlaufen und so.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Ich lasse das Video...
Ich lasse...
Ich scrolle das Video jetzt mal durch.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass am Ende irgendwelche NSFW-Bilder kommen und ich gebannt werde, ja?
Oh, es gibt sogar Sound dabei.
Echt? Das ist schon eine coole Idee.
Sind auch ganz brauchbare Models.
Kennt man ein bisschen Details dran.
Und was ist der Anwendungszweck davon jetzt?
Also ist das für Verkäufer gedacht?
ETF?
Uah, C++, G++.
Weg.
Anwendung der Bachelor bestehen.
naja aber wenn sogar eine eigene website alles gibt muss da schon ein bisschen
bisschen gedanken dahinter sein
zukünftiger jobtitel vibecode maintainer ja das wird das wird das wird natürlich
bessere namen bekommen senior ki expert oder irgendwie sowas
Achso, wo war das jetzt hier mit dem Vibe-Code? Ich habe es nicht gesehen. Habe ich recht? Hier. Genau. Ähm. JavaScript tatsächlich. Okay. Das ist tatsächlich auch nicht so blöd. KI-Modelle sind relativ gut, was JavaScript angeht. Python machen die glaube ich auch ganz gut.
Das ist für die Leute
Die sich ihr Auto konfiguriert haben
Und um die Zeit zu überbrücken
Das ist eine coole Sache
Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen
Dass das richtig gut ist, wenn du sowas verkaufen willst
Ja, weil letztendlich
Wer solche Luxusautos verkauft
Die verkaufen ja immer so ein gewisses
So einen gewissen Vibe quasi mit
Warum die Leute das kaufen
Und
wenn du da nicht nur sagen kannst, oh, sie bekommen
das und das und das und hier, sondern
hier können sie sich quasi schon mal live reinsetzen.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen, ist das
für den Verkauf auch richtig geil.
Finde ich eine coole Idee.
Metaverse.
Metaverse is dead.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Facebook schon offiziell gesagt hat, dass es Dead ist, aber es ist Dead.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe nie irgendwas Sinnvolles gesehen vom Metaverse.
Die haben ja da Millionen, wenn nicht Milliarden reingesteckt.
eingesteckt.
Das Einzige, was ich zum Metaverse
im Hinterkopf hab, ist
dieses billige
Video oder Bild
vom Zug
vom Eiffelturm.
Das hier, was aussieht
wie
Vibe Coded in Unity in 5 Minuten.
Das hier, ja.
Das meine ich.
das sieht so dermaßen billig und kacke aus
das ist das einzige was ich mit metaverse irgendwie verbinde das musst du nicht mal
vibe coden in unity jeder der unity installiert hat kann er das in fünf
minuten machen wahrscheinlich sah second life besser aus ich hab second life
Glücklicherweise ging das an mir vorbei.
Das ist so...
Also allein schon wie...
Wie in seiner eigenen...
Wie nennt man das?
Wenn du nur Leute um dich drum herum hast, die dir in den Arsch kriechen, ja?
Wie sehr in seiner eigenen Arschkriechblase kann man sein,
dass man sowas öffentlich postet und denkt, man hat jetzt quasi voll was Revolutionäres gepostet.
Da hat sich bestimmt einfach keiner getraut zu sagen, ey, zuck.
Irgendwie sieht das billig aus.
Und nach fünf Minuten Unity-Tutorial.
Aber da hatten wir es ja schon von.
So machst du keine Karriere.
Du machst am besten Karriere, wenn du dann das gleiche Horn bläst.
Wo wir dabei sind, so machst du keine Karriere.
guck dir an wohin meter geht ehrlich gesagt ich keine ahnung und mich
interessiert so nicht was meter gerade so treibt ich habe zwar einen facebook
account keinen privaten für für max fps facebook account da habe ich seit
keine ahnung acht jahren oder so nichts mal drauf gepostet
das habe ich nur damals gemacht weil viele leute auf facebook waren ansonsten
ich bin noch nicht mal sicher ob ich da überhaupt noch das login für habe
Ja, 2018.
Muss noch was erzählen, wird länger.
Ich muss gleich, ich bin 5 Minuten weg, ja.
Also bei dem öffentlichen Dienst, wo ich jetzt FISI mache,
habe ich davor ein Jahr Anwendungsentwicklung gemacht,
allerdings wurde da kaum programmiert oder irgendwas in diese Richtung gemacht.
Alle Kollegen, auch der zweite Chef, sagten, FISI macht viel mehr Sinn,
Aber der oberste Chef in der IT damals sagt, nein, ich bleibe Anwendungsentwickler, obwohl ich gefragt habe, ob ich Fachrichtung wechseln kann.
Nun hast du ja, der alte Chef ist nicht mehr da und die haben direkt Physi ausgeschrieben.
Ja, kannst du nicht dann eh schon ein Jahr abkürzen, wenn du schon gerade in der Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwickler-Ausbildung bist?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich was, wo es nicht verkehrt ist, bei der IHK zu fragen.
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, nach der Ausbildung...
...habe ich hoffentlich nie wieder was mit der IHK zu tun.
Habe ich aber falsch gedacht.
Seitdem ich das Gewerbe angemeldet habe vor ein paar Jahren...
...vor ein paar Jahren ist gut.
Das ist 14 Jahre oder so her.
Seit ich das Gewerbe angemeldet habe, wurde ich zwangsrekrutiert zur IHK.
Muss dort irgendwie, was weiß ich, 60 Euro, weiß nicht wie viel es ist, bezahlen.
Und kriege immer so eine komische Mitgliederzeitung von denen, die ich Insta in den Müll schmeiße.
Und ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was, warum.
Ich will von denen überhaupt nichts.
Okay, also geht weiter.
Also er ist dann da hin, hat mit denen geredet, musste den ganzen Bewerbungsprozess noch machen.
Und die haben sich wieder für mich entschieden, weil die Kollegen meinten, ich war super damals.
Du warst doch immer noch bei denen.
Oder warst du zwischenzeitlich woanders?
Achso, ah, okay.
Bin damals weg zur Bahn.
Okay, du hast da aber wildes Hin und Her hinter dir.
Aber wenn das öffentliche Dienst ist, hast du doch auch ganz gute Chancen übernommen zu werden, oder?
Wie ist das da?
Die bilden ja bestimmt aus, weil sie selbst Leute brauchen.
Also da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass du da ganz gute Chancen hast.
Zumindest wenn du dann...
Du könntest ja theoretisch auch verkürzen.
Also gerade wenn du schon mal Anwendungsentwickler gemacht hast,
müsste das eigentlich gehen.
Muss man die IHK fragen.
Also falls du überhaupt willst, kannst du auch nicht länger Berufsschule entspannt genießen.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Das Einzige, was ich machen würde, ist, wenn sich die Ausbildung dem Ende nähert,
die ist ja noch lange hin, dann schon mal gucken, wie das mit Übernahme aussieht
und sich nicht so sehr auf irgendwelche Versprechen verlassen, so nach dem Motto,
ja, ja, jetzt mach erstmal die Ausbildung fertig oder ja, ja, das machen wir dann so wie immer,
ja das kommt noch, sondern wenn die nicht zu Potte kommen, zumindest schon mal extern ein bisschen suchen.
Ja, dich schon mal ein bisschen angucken, was es da so gibt, weil, wie gesagt, also, da wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
da hatten wir 200 Mitarbeiter, 50 davon waren Azubis und die haben da auch diesen Kram gemacht.
Die haben den Leuten immer erzählt,
ja, ja, Übernahme, reine Formsache
und ja, wir machen das wie immer und so bla bla bla bla
und da haben sie auf einmal auch ganz viele nicht übernommen.
Obwohl die das denen immer erzählt haben.
Und die Leute, die dann nicht geguckt haben,
haben die dann auch teilweise gesagt,
ja, wir übernehmen dich,
aber
es waren halt dann miese Bedingungen
und die Leute mussten es dann halt nehmen.
Es war aber ein Kackladen.
Ganz ehrlich, mein Ausbildungsbetrieb
war ein richtiger Kackladen.
Kann ich jetzt so im Nachhinein sagen.
Aber die Ausbildung war gut, weil sie nicht existent war.
Es gab keine Ausbildung.
Entweder hast du die Sachen gelernt und gemacht, da konntest du alles machen und alles lernen.
Oder du hast nichts gemacht.
Dann hätte beides funktioniert.
Aber eine Ausbildung, also Ausbilder gab es nicht.
Einen Plan gab es nicht.
Es gab gar nichts.
Die hatten die Azubis, also in dem Betrieb, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe, die hatten die Azubis, ist meine persönliche Vermutung, weil die billig waren, um Server und Sachen durch Deutschland zu fahren.
Die waren billiger. Die konnten dann nämlich gleich ins Auto steigen, Server einpacken, Server wohin fahren, Server einbauen, Server in Betrieb nehmen, gucken, dass alles läuft und dann zurückfahren.
Und wir hatten Azubis, die sind quasi mehr oder weniger die ganze Woche quer durch Deutschland gefahren.
Wie ist denn bei Seagate HDDs die Lautstärke in einem Nass?
Also meistens sollten HDDs ja im Sleep sein.
Dann ist die Lautstärke egal.
Und der Axis, nachdem das 24 7 Nassplatten sind, würde ich mal sagen, das sind wahrscheinlich nicht die allerleisesten Platten.
Wie laut die jetzt wirklich sind, keine Ahnung.
Fürs Wohnzimmer, weiß ich nicht, ob es da wirklich magnetfest Platten sein müssen.
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also, wenn du das jetzt irgendwie so als Medienserver verwenden willst,
ja, dann müssen es Platten sein.
Da sind SSDs noch zu klein, beziehungsweise in der Masse zu teuer.
Aber wenn du da ja quasi nur dreimal am Tag drauf zugreifst abends,
kannst du dir vielleicht auch andere Platten kaufen und die dann im Deep Sleep den ganzen Tag.
Und abends gehen sie an.
Aber Nassplatten sind schon nicht verkehrt
Aber
Da würde ich vielleicht gucken, dass es nicht im Wohnzimmer steht
Aber musst du gucken
WD Greens mag ich überhaupt nicht
Ich hatte auch mal ein paar
Tatsächlich in
Hier als ich 2013 eingezogen bin
Die erste Kiste, die ich hier gebaut habe
Damals noch mit Raid 6.
Die hatte
WD Greens.
So viele Platten sind mir noch nie kaputt gegangen.
Im jetzigen NAS
habe ich auch Seagate Einwolf drin.
Da ist noch nicht eine kaputt gegangen.
So, Chat.
Das war heute spontaner Stream.
Werbung, ja da müssen wir uns noch einmal Sellout machen.
Bevor der Stream zu Ende ist, Sellout.
Wenn ihr auf der Suche seid, Leute, nach günstigen, festplatten und energiesparenden Nasssystemen,
könnt ihr im Chat Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Alternate, Ausrufezeichen Seagate
oder bei mir im Profil gucken und den Revlink anklicken.
Oder den Link, der hier gerade im Chat steht.
Dann könnt ihr euch das Ganze anschauen, ob da was für euch dabei ist.
Und die Preise hier gibt es nur über meinen Link.
Anderweitig sind die Dinger teurer.
Also immer schön über den Revlink kaufen.
Wenn ihr was kaufen wollt.
Nice.
So, Sellout erledigt.
Chat, ich muss jetzt off.
War heute spontaner Stream.
Ehrlich gesagt wollte ich gar nicht streamen.
Ich habe aus zwei Gründen gestreamt.
Einmal, weil ich Bock hatte mit euch ein bisschen zu schwätzen.
Und ich sonst nichts großartig zu tun hatte.
Und wegen der Viewbot-Geschichte.
Also, macht's gut.
Bis, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann ich wieder da bin, spätestens, allerspätestens Sonntagmorgen zum Aufwachen streamen.
Dann wieder ordentlich vier Stunden plus.
Ja, RF-Programmer, ich guck mal, ob ich morgen oder Samstag noch onkomme.
Was will das hier von mir?
Chat, wie kann ich jetzt rausfinden, was das hier ist?
Oh.
Sollte ich das hier jetzt öffnen?
Äh.
Und jetzt?
Was war das?
Hä?
One or more
Driver?
Bugatti gekauft?
Fuck!
Ja, hat das jetzt den Kram installiert, oder was?
Alter, Windows hat checkt.
Da stand Software.
Was stand da?
Ich muss das gerade mal angucken.
Dass ich danach noch mal googeln kann.
Weil es ist bei Windows ja mittlerweile so, dass viele Windows Sachen
Vibe-Coded Bullshit sind und wenn ich danach suche, kann es sein, dass ich jetzt 50 Reddit Sachen
50 Reddit Sachen finde
Hier
Finish Installing Device Software
About it won't tell me
Genau
Ich glaube ich weiß was das ist
Mein Endplus
Stick
Für den
Smart Trainer
Nothing happens, wenn man das klickt.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Also.
Ja, whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
Windows Shit.
Man weiß es nicht.
Chat, ich bin off. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.